the policies of Federal Reserve Chairman
Alan Greenspan in his new book
greenspan's fraud he spoke about it
recently at Loyola Marymount University
in Los Angeles
it's an hour in 20 minutes ravi batra
inclination towards spirituality was
initiated early in his life after
reading the Gita and other books of
Eastern spirituality add to this the
influence of spiritual master Ananda
Musti who inspired young Bhadra to
become a loving helper to those in need
while Batra was simultaneously being
taught by professor Bhagwati and Nobel
laureate professor Matias Sam for his
master's degree but Rah's extra-ordinary
spirituality and devotion to God led him
to sometimes 20 hours a week of
meditation and prayer transforming him
more into what appeared to be a student
of saint Meera Bai and Saint Teresa
rather than a student of economics but
eventually received his PhD in economics
from Southern Illinois University in
1969 and he later joined the Department
of Economics in Southern Methodist
University where he became one of the
youngest faculty members to become a
full professor with tenure at 30 years
of age so that takes care of the
spiritual part now about his
professional part dr. ravi batra a
professor of economics at Southern
Methodist University is the author of
five international bestsellers he was
the chairperson of his department from
1977 to 1980 in October 1978 because of
dozens of publications in the likes of
America
an Economic Review Journal of political
economy econometric our Journal of
economic theory review of economic
studies and many others Butler was
ranked third in a group of superstar
economists selected by the American and
Canadian universities by an article in a
learner Journal of economic inquiry in
1990 the Italian Prime Minister awarded
him a medal of Italian Senate for
writing a book that correctly predicted
the powerful Soviet Communism 15 years
after it happened
dr. Batra has been written up in many
major newspapers and magazines such as
New York Times Washington Post USA Today
Time Newsweek the US News & World Report
and appeared in all major networks
including CBS NBC CNN ABC and CNBC among
others I won't take much of your time we
also have recording here by c-span
people and I just want to say that I
have only two books left if anyone wants
to get professor betras book with a
signature professor Batra please come
[Applause]
thank you very much for coming here to
listen to me and giving me the
opportunity to share my thoughts with
you yes I've written a book called
greenspan's fraud and it's only
appropriate that this lecture is being
sponsored by the department of religion
and spirituality here rather than by the
economics department because those who
are in the vanguard of exposing fraud
especially of official fraud are the
true-true spiritualists fraud is
committed by a lot of people and the
fraud goes undetected detected for a
long time and that is because it's very
difficult to expose it and so those who
come forward and help around in exposing
it or the true spiritualists and
religious people at least in my view
well why do I think that Greenspan Alan
Greenspan the maestro the person who's
adored and adored by the rest of the
world especially by Wall Street by
multinational firms why did what do I
think that such a person has actually
committed fraud why can't I just call it
Greenspan's Follies Greenspan's mistakes
because fraud is something that is
intentional something that a person does
knowingly am i accusing him of that well
from his actions from his words there's
a lot of circumstantial evidence that
there is intent in doing something which
is now
right let's go to the early 1980s
especially the Year 1980 and 81 Reagan
had just been elected he had promised a
major tax cut which was passed in 1981
Alan Greenspan was his advisor at that
time after the tax cut was passed there
was a huge jump in the budget deficit
government's budget deficit that deficit
was not anticipated that was not
expected and those days the budget
deficit did create lot of ripples in the
economy today people yawn when they hear
of the budget deficit but those days
inflation was very high in the United
States and that budget deficit created a
huge jump in the rate of interest today
you can borrow money to buy a house at
6% at that time you had to pay 15 16 18
percent to borrow money to buy a house
so interest rates had jumped and jumping
interest rates had actually crushed the
US economy and everybody every
Republican was concerned Reagan was in
really in bad shape he was not his
ratings were low and at the same time
there was a parallel Christ not a crisis
but a minor problem
in Social Security Social Security had
faced some deficit and Greenspan was
appointed the chairman of the Social
Security Commission to solve the problem
of the SSA or the Social Security
Administration that was in 1981 he
became the chairman of that Commission
in 1981 and within a year after he
became the chairman
that government's budget deficit was
extremely high so he knew that the only
way to improve the economy the only way
to improve Reagan's chances of
re-election was to bring the budget
deficit down but how do you bring the
budget deficit down the government's
budget deficit down when you can't touch
the income tax rate the tax rate had
already been cut in 1981 and by 1982-83
the budget deficit was so high how do
you bring that deficit down if you can't
touch the income tax rate because Reagan
would not approve of it if he did he
would have to eat a humble pie he would
have to admit that he had done something
awful to the economy so Greenspan came
up with an idea he came up came up with
an idea let's raise up raise the payroll
tax why because the Social Security
system will face would face face a major
crisis 50 to 60 years from the early
eighties I mean you ask a person to give
you more tax today today's for today's
problems nobody will do that he was
asking Americans to pay higher payroll
taxes because the problem would arise 50
to 60 years from that time but let's
take a look at what the real problem is
is it in the Social Security budget or
is it in the government's budget that's
what the comparison of what the toussis
two sides need one side is the federal
government and the other side is the
Social Security Security Administration
which one is in greater need of funds
let's take a look at that
thank you here I have a table if you
look at the top it says operations of
the combined OASDI trust fund
OAS di is the name for the Social
Security trust fund and then the federal
government in these selected years and
let's forget the earlier years let's
just go to the years from 1975 to 1983
so you see well assist if there's a
negative sign that means there's a
surplus otherwise there is a deficit so
look at the funds deficit from 1975 to
83 in 83 there is a surplus in the trust
fund the trust fund was going to correct
itself there was a deficit from 75 to 83
with the trust fund deficit was
correcting itself in any case the total
deficit is 28 billion dollars the last
last row and then look at the final
column here look at the federal deficit
deficit of the federal government from
75 to 83 four hundred and ninety billion
dollars so there is the real problem the
problem is with the federal deficit but
here greenspan comes up with the theory
the real problem is with the Social
Security Administration not with the
federal deficit so he wants to solve
that problem so he proposed a rise in
the payroll tax he proposed a rise in
the payroll tax as you can see in the
current period there was not much
problem in 83 itself the fund was the
Social Security trust fund was
correcting itself it had a surplus so in
the current period there is no problem
so he had to come up with a scheme in
the scheme was well right now we don't
have a big problem with the fund with
the system but 50 to 60 years from now
the fund would be in great def I said we
would need to raise taxes extreme
sharply at that time why don't we start
collecting a surplus now in that fund so
that taxes do not have to be raised too
much in the future
so he convinced the people that we need
social security reform but the intent
was to raise the revenues to fund the
deficit of the federal government that's
the fraud how do we know that was his
intent first of all we know that there's
nothing in that Social Security trust
fund right now they did raise the
payroll tax sharply in 1983 to collect
it correctly to create a surplus where
is the surplus there is no surplus two
trillion dollars worth of extra taxes
collected from the middle class and the
poor they have been used up by the
government to fund its own operations so
in my view Greenspan has committed
Social Security fraud and the fraud is
he sold his plane as Social Security
reform but he helped to raise funds for
the government and meet its own expenses
that's one problem with what he did but
there is a lot more evidences than just
this in April of 1983 legislation was
passed to sharply raise the payroll tax
and the promise was we will raise your
parent payroll tax now so we can
guarantee your benefits in the future
otherwise people won't agree so people
would get guaranteed benefits in the
future in exchange for higher payroll
taxes from 1984 onwards from right in
1984 on the legislation was passed in
April 1983 six months after that law the
law has not even gone into effect
because the law would go in fact to into
effect in 84
six months after that law was passed
Greenspan has a reporter
we have to cut these manage social
social security benefits because the
budget deficit is rising it's too high
that is not the purpose of Social
Security to finance the federal deficit
and he's saying that six months after
the law was passed now he knows the law
cannot be repealed taxes has been raised
already the law cannot be repealed so he
starts saying well let's start cutting
the deficit and he should not be even
saying that because his commission had
promised earlier that Social Security
funds should not be used for the purpose
of the federal budget but he started
undermining his own law so you can see
the intent was not to fund the Social
Security for the future but the intent
was to correct the the budget problems
and then giesemann went on and on kept
talking about reducing the benefits of
the Social Security Administration which
he should not be because as I said
before Social Security is a separate
program it has its own funds and it is
not supposed to be used to finance the
operations of the federal government but
Greenspan kept undermining his own
legislation which very in which he was
heavily involved now many people ask me
why do you blame Greenspan for this
because many other politicians were also
part of this this scheme the reason I
blame cleans greens there first of all
other politicians have come and gone
lawmakers and presidents come and go
Greenspan stays in power forever and so
he's the main person who's responsible
he knew what has really happened he
should remind lawmakers and the
presidents that the real purpose of that
payroll tax was to create a surplus in
the fund not to use the money for
federal government so it's his
responsibility and he's not doing that
secondly he did certain things which
other politicians did not do like they
did not
start saying let's cut the social
security benefits he is the one who
first offered that legislation and then
immediately I'll almost immediately
started to say let's cut the funds let's
cut the benefits so he's undermining his
own promise his own law which other
politicians did not do so I so what I
say is that yes others are all others
are also involved but Greenspan was the
ringleader in this fraud then came 1999
and I'm cutting there's a there are a
lot of aspects of to the fraud but I'm
cutting it short for instance in 1990
itself there was Senator Moynihan he
discovered that the Social Security Law
was really being undermined there was no
surplus anymore so he offered his
legislation to repeal parts of the
increase in the payroll tax he said you
know there's no surplus being created so
why are we collecting extra extra funds
from the people Greenspan rejected that
legislation in 1990 so again you can see
the purpose of the tax that he as he had
helped pass the purpose was to create
extra funds for the government not for
the Social Security system until 99 the
government had budget deficits and the
surplus revenue of the trust fund was
used for those deficits but then if you
recall from 1999 to 2001 the budget had
small surplus I'm sure you remember that
now Greenspan told the legislators at
that time
let's now we have the opportunity to
create this surplus
the Republicans wanted to cut taxes at
that time recent suspend said no don't
cut the text let's really have the
surplus why because the these
projections of budget surplus can be
easily can easily go wrong there were a
lot of projections coming out that the
surplus could last 10 15 years from now
and then it could go it could be five
trillion six trillion if you recall
those wild projections about the budget
surplus and Greenspan acted wisely for
once and he said these budget
projections can be easily wrong so let's
actually create a real surplus and that
will fund Social Security that was in
1999 in 2001 when after Bush was elected
he testifies there could be 800 billion
per year per year 800 billion dollars
per year of surplus in the near future
in by 2010 or 2011 800 billion dollars
per year per year of surplus he was
projecting for the future now that Bush
was elected he said let's cut the income
tax in 99 he says don't cut the income
tax because projection could be wrong in
2001 he says let's cut the income tax
because the projections say that we
could have 800 million dollars per year
of surplus in 2010 he's contradicting
himself now rejections are could be
right once Bush was elected so so to me
it appear that he has committed two
types of frauds one is the Social
Security fraud I just mentioned and the
other is intellectual fraud now what's
an intellectual fraud where somebody a
man of high intelligence high IQ changes
his or her theories where the man
changes his theories constantly for
personal gain that to me is intellectual
fraud
and let's take a look at a chart which
will show how often greenspan changed
his views for a certain purpose
this table talks about Greenspan's
intellectual fraud over three decades so
in nineteen from 1977 to 1979 Greenspan
advises against and income tax cut
faults inflationary potential he said
you know income tax cuts create budget
deficits which in turn create inflation
that was his theory at that time then
Reagan got elected see what he says now
dream spend Beck's income tax cuts to
fight inflation that's the contradiction
that's 100 degree 80 degree turn around
now he wants to fight inflation through
income tax cuts then in 82 83 he backs a
gasoline tax rise Social Security tax I
really theta to lower the deficit so now
he's saying we needed tax rise to lower
the interest rate because the budget
deficit is breaking records but remember
remember he still cannot bring income
tax to his lips he wants to raise all
other taxes except income tax except the
income tax that's because Reagan would
not like the rise in income tax so he's
changing theories about tax system and
so on
it should go on and on you see this 1991
$2.99 I mean spent years it changes his
theories again he goes back to whatever
he was riding under Carter that budget
deficits are inflationary generate high
interest rates so spending should be cut
substantially he opposed the income tax
cut under plate Clinton does
contradicting his earlier support for
Reagan's program in 2000 from 2000 to
2004 he backs the Bush income tax cut so
there are lot of inconsistencies as a
simple example he's opposed a cut in the
income tax under President Carter
supported it under Reagan apposite under
Clinton supported it under President
Bush susi same thing but offering doing
but often different theories for the
same idea now why is he doing that he's
changing his theories but what's the
proof that he's changing it changing
them in self-interest well
in the late 70s he wanted to make
friends with the Republicans because
they were out of power Carter was
President Carter was president so he
opposed whatever Carter proposed so as
yes I became very friendly with the
Republicans and when Reagan came to
power he joined the Reagan team and so
now he wants Reagan to succeed to bring
success to Reagan he needs to bring the
budget deficit down so he proposes a
rise in the Social Security tax but
supports the supports the cut in the
income tax then Reagan appointed him as
the chairman of the Federal Reserve
what were his qualifications then as a
banker he had never been a banker he had
never been a banker what was his
qualification as a banker well he had
loaned money to alter burns in the 70s
who was a Fed Chairman during the 1970s
so that was his banking experience he
lent money to the Fed Chairman at that
time but he knew the Fed Chairman very
well so the Fed Chairman gave a
recommendation later on to Reagan and
they again appointed him as the chairman
of the Federal Reserve in 1987 Greenspan
had become the chairman of Economic
Advisers in 1974 under President Ford he
did not even have a PhD in economics at
that time had a master's degree he had
never written an article in a scholarly
acknowledged journal yes he had written
some articles in a newsletter on
economics but not in a scholarly
scholarly journal yet he had become the
chairman of Economic Advisers and once
you have reached a certain
level posts in government you make
friends in the White House and as a
result later on he was appointed as
chairman of the Federal Reserve in 1987
so why was he changing his theories I
gave you one example he wanted to curry
favor with Reagan so he changed his
theory in theories in 1982 81 and 83
once he became the chairman of the
Federal Reserve he began to court Wall
Street he had found that Wall Street was
the key to long tenure for a Fed
Chairman now he did not really drink and
all the other Republicans so he started
to follow policies that favor Wall
Street so what happened then we find
that he followed independent policies he
angered the Republicans and if you
recall that's why at least the
Republicans claim that's why George Bush
Senior was defeated in 1992 in 1992
because he angered the Republicans he
raised interest rates in order to
control inflation Wall Street likes low
inflation so he raised interest rates to
curry favor with them and Wall Street
was very happy with with Alan Greenspan
and he was reappointed even though the
Republican president and Republican
lawmakers were some of them were very
unhappy with what he had done later in
96 or by 96 he had angered the Democrats
by raising interest rates during their
time and as a result in 1995 I think or
was in 94 the Republicans took control
of the house so the Democrats were very
unhappy with him but Wall Street was
happy so he was reappointed again
because Wall Street matters a lot in the
math in the matter of
the appointment of the qualified
chairman but then you see if you
remember there was a stock market crash
in 2000 2001 and 2002 so by now Wall
Street was very unhappy with him so what
do you do if you want to be reappointed
go back to what he had done go back to
doing what you do what he had done to
court Reagan so I quotes George Bush
supports his policies he knows Wall
Street is worrying unhappy with him
people had lots lost seven trillion
dollars of money at least on paper they
were a people favored wealth from that
stock market crash so he now began to
support Reagan he supported rigged a
sorry Bush his supported Bush's income
tax cuts and later on he said let's make
all these tax cuts permanent so see he's
changing his theories opinions
statements so that he can be reappointed
he's the president and he needs him his
with Wall Street when he needs them when
the one Wall Street quits on him he goes
back to the President and so on I've
been doing some radio shows some TV in
the past one week and I told people that
I don't think these spend is going to
leave in January 2006 when he's supposed
to resign his turn expires and they said
why I said well don't you see his
courting he's supporting everything that
George Bush wants right now because the
president is the only person who can who
can extend his tenure if the president
does not appoint anybody else does not
nominate anybody else mean span can stay
on as interim chairman until 2008 and
then somebody just told me that there
was an article in Washington Post saying
that Greenspan is going to stay on
longer than 2006 and so on so I'm not
surprised he's that's what he wants he
wants power
he loves pollen and in pursuit of that
power he has been changing his theories
again and again and that to me is
intellectual fraud lots of people are
dishonest lots of people commit fraud
what they don't have extremely bad
effect effects on the economy what dream
spans fraud have had really bad effect
horrible effects on the US and world
economy I'll show you some of the some
of these charts now it can compare what
the economy was in the 1950s and the
1960s and what it has been since 1980
people think he has created a tremendous
tremendous prosperity for the United
States but things have to be seen in
perspective
first of all I believe that Greenspan
has created what what I call a system of
robber baron taxation robbed the poor
and award the well-to-do with tax cuts
robbed the poor with Inc Social Security
tax increases and reward the well-to-do
with income tax cuts that is what I
think what I call robber baron type of
taxation and it's unethical
I think economic policy in the 50s and
the 60s who are highly ethical the poor
and the destitute did not have to pay
high taxes Social Security tax averaged
some 3% per person per individual they
were very low gasoline taxes and so on
so he created a system of regressive
taxation starting from from around 1980
and see what that system does
we're looking at GDP growth rates
corporate corporate income taxes and top
bracket income tax rates top bracket
income tax may be called the CEO tax
because that's who it really affects so
you can see the corporate tax rate is
coming down from the 50s onto right now
see it used to be 52% and now it's just
33% and that is if the corporation's pay
any tax at all if the pay any tax if
they declare any profit the tax is just
33% now and then look at the top bracket
income tax they just the average this as
high as eighty nine percent eighty
percent seventy percent you know it said
they're coming down and down and this is
this is supposed to create tremendous
investment opportunities investment
incentives and raise sharply raise
economic growth but look what is
happening to it coming out average
annual growth is four point one percent
in the 50s four point four percent in
the 60s
comes down in the seventies we can
disregard seventies if you like because
that was distorted by high oil prices
but even eighties and now it's it's just
stagnant compared to what it was in the
40s in the 50s when the fifties in the
60s so the claim that Greenspan has
sharply increased prosperity in the
United States is not supported by
history it not is not supported by
historical facts
why would regressive taxation or robber
baron taxation reduce economic growth
nobody wants to produce things for their
own consumption they produce things for
sale they want to sell their goods to
the public if you raise taxes on on the
poor in the middle class and cut them
for the CEOs consumer spending is bound
to fall consumer demand will not grow as
fast as before so if consumer demand
does not grow as fast as before
production will not rise as fast as
before so as simple as that regressive
taxation or robber baron taxation will
definitely cause a cut in gdp growth and
we have seen that that's supported by
history these are the facts that come
from the economic report of the
president each year that report is
published and these facts come from that
report so the tax system that Greenspan
has created has led tresh has led to a
sharply lower level of growth but then
why did we have such a booming stock
market you know you have lower growth
but a booming stock mode that's also
because of what being spended he created
policies that brought real wages down
the purchasing power of wages down wages
are the main source of demand
productivity is the main source of
supply in the 50s and the 60s wages kept
up with productivity so demand kept up
with supply in the last few years wages
lagged behind productivity so supply was
ahead of demand how do you balance this
kind of system
supplies ahead of demand supply is
greater than demand how do you balance
this kind of system by creating debt by
lowering the interest rate and lowering
more and more people into debt so debt
also raises debate so that's what's
happening
that raises demand to balance to create
a balance in the economy and once that
balance is created profits skyrocket why
why do the skyrocket because wages are
not keeping up with productivity so
there is stock market bubble stock
market bubbles have occurred only when
wages trail productivity in the economy
they have never occurred at any other
time this happened in the during the
1920s and now since between 1982 and
2000 wages stale productivity wages the
behind productivity both in both periods
and therefore we had the stock market
bubble so stock market bubble is not the
product of a strong economy is the
product of wages trailing productivity
and of course huge debt at the same time
so when Greenspan follows these debt
creating policies he's not doing any
favor to the economy it's in the
interests of the government's stability
the government won't be reelected if it
did not follow those policies he has to
stabilize the economy through the
creation of debt and today you know that
is so high because of all that what what
are the things he has done he would
abolish the minimum wage what's the
theory there the theory is that a rise
in the minimum wage laws employment and
raises unemployment I mean you just look
at history again and again and see how
totally wrong he is
okay
this table looks at the change in the
minimum wage and in employment a year
later you know the minimum wage rises
and you want to see what effect it has
on employment within within within a
year between from 1950 to 1997 the
minimum wage went up 17 times since 97
it has been frozen at 515 the minimum
wage went up 17 times from 1950 to 97
now look at the employment change almost
always it is positive you know
employment changes in thousands so in
1950 a million more people are employed
when the minimum wage went up almost
always there is a rise in employment
within the year after the minimum wage
rises now in three years you have
negative numbers 74-81 1990 but these
are the three years in which oil prices
jumped sharply so take away the effect
of the rise in the price of oil it's
clear that every time minimum of the
minimum wage rises employment jobs
totally destroying in Greenspan's
thought this is another fraud on the
people that the rising minimum wage
raises unemployment or lowers employment
17 times it happens there is not a
single period take out the oil price
effect this is not a single period in
which employment fell why does the rise
in the minimum wage raise employment
same reason as before the rise in the
minimum wage raises consumer demand
consumer spending rising consumer
spending in whites producers to produce
more companies build more
products produce more growth Rises
employment rises so this book is not
just about Greenspan not just about
greenspan's fraud but also the effects
it has created for the economy and today
we have 36 million people who live below
the poverty line 36 million people in
America live below the poverty line and
you say you asked
Why should there be any poverty today at
all hey we are in the age of the
Internet we have computer revolution
productivity is so high
Why should there be poverty in a country
like the United States when productivity
is so high well the trouble is the
economic policies are so bad then in
spite of higher productivity poverty is
close to its record 36 million people
are unemployed today live below poverty
today compared to 23 million in 1965 or
something something like that
why is poverty rising when we have such
productivity bad policies bankruptcies
are breaking records real wages are
falling but the worst of all is that we
have a huge trade deficit we blame it on
China and Japan of course those two
countries are a big part of that trade
deficit but why why doesn't trade
deficit now respond to the falling
dollar you know the theory is when your
currency depreciates the deficit should
fall in the 70s the dollar fell sharply
and the deficit America had some deficit
in that in trade in the 70s the deficit
disappeared why don't we do that why
doesn't the same thing happened now the
dollar is falling but the deficit
continues to rise well here comes
Greenspan again
to economists free-trade means the
removal of tariffs that's for the most
most economists talk think of free trade
Greenspan added another thing to the
idea of free trade
he added financial deregulation around
the world that financial deregulation
made it easy for other countries to send
money into the United States and Finance
America's trade deficit so it made it
easier for the deficit trade deficit to
rise but in the process America's
manufacturing base was decimated today
eleven percent of the labor force works
in manufacturing we have to go back to
the Civil War and the time period around
that to see that kind of lower level of
employment in manufacturing so when your
manufacturing base disappears you can
reduce the value of the dollar as much
as you like but what are you going to
export are we going to export our cars
no they don't want these cars are we
going to export motorcycles we are
produced in here TVs VCRs they're not
produced here what I do to export when
your manufacturing base has disappeared
so the dollar can fall and fall fall and
fall the trade deficit is not going to
fall because there is no manufacturing
thanks to Greenspan well you say mr.
Batra you have been talking about all
these problems is there any solution yes
there is a simple solution if the will
is there how can the the biggest problem
facing the country today is the straight
deficit it's eating away our economy we
need two billion dollars subsidy from
the rest of the world to stay afloat and
that's not a healthy state of affairs
so I have a long chapter on economic
reform in the book but I'll talk only
about this solution of about the trade
deficit how we can at least cut it in
half without offending even China in
Japan there is a very simple way see
right now Congress wars China to revalue
its currency in fact today's newspapers
are full of that that they're forcing
China to revalue its currency say the
China raises the value of the worn by
say 10% will that have an effect on the
weather the trade deficit with China No
are you not going to buy Chinese goods
just because their prices rise by 10
percent who is going to care about a 10
percent rise in prices in fact the trade
deficit with China will get worse
because we keep buying Chinese goods and
simply pay them more dollars for their
more that will make it worse and of
course we all know that even 10%
revaluation will be very difficult to
get from China but if we get there that
things will get worse America has export
prices to China have to fall by a lot
more than 10% they have to be they have
to fall by 50 60 % in China would never
go for that kind of revaluation in its
currency and even if we force that kind
of move on China American importers will
cry foul Walmart will be very unhappy
Target stores will be very unhappy so
they won't let that happen so what do we
do so I have come up with a simple
solution of a dual exchange rate system
you know the exchange rates are set by
being set by China for for the war and
for by Japan for the yen but it
shouldn't it can't be a one-way street
the exchange rates are always two-way
streets we can do the same thing we can
set an exchange rate also with respect
to the war and with respect to the yen
but of course we don't want to offend
our importers Walmart and so on so there
is a way in which we can cut our export
prices without raising the import prices
Walmart and the targets these stores
they are afraid that import prices will
rise and that will kill their businesses
so here is the system I'm proposing
which will cut only America's export
prices to other countries without
raising import prices how can we do that
if we can do that I think that solves
the problem if you don't raise import
prices China won't be unhappy Japan
won't be unhappy and we if we cut our
export prices at the same time their
importers will be happy to buy our goods
so how do we do that
think about it for a while while I have
some water
suppose we have a system of dual
exchange rates one exchange rate which
is a free-market exchange rate set by
market forces and that applies to all
transactions except our exports and we
set up another control exchange rate
which applies only to our exports or
foreign imports let me give you an
example right now the value of the
chinese vaughn is what eight point two
eight to one dollar that's the value
suppose we unilaterally set it up to say
six one to $1 and we say this is what we
are setting it up setting it up we're
fixing it for our exporters or their
importers for all of the transactions
the free market value of the dollar
matters but only for our exports and
other imports we will set an exchange
rate of six one to the dollar now what
will happen the importer in China to buy
American products right now has to pay
eight point two eight one two the
Chinese government gets $1 imports goods
from America but if we set it up at six
one he will go to the Federal Reserve
pay 6 1 get 1 dollar and import goods
into China his prices have fallen
sharply for American goods his price has
fallen sharply he has to pay only 6 1 to
the Fed get a dollar buy American goods
import them into China export price has
fallen but import price has not risen
why Walmart will go to China for $1 they
can get eight point two eight what they
won't want go to the moon fall to go to
the Fed they'll go to China because for
one dollar they can still get eight
point two eight four then they will buy
goods with that Chinese currency bring
them back
import prices have not risen export
prices fall and this is under your
control you can set it up unilaterally
you can do it on your own without
offending the Chinese government because
it's not going to raise the prices of
Chinese goods in America it won't offend
Walmart not Target stores will be will
not be unhappy so we can set unilateral
exchange rates with respect to all the
countries with which we have a huge
trade deficit with Japan we can say well
we have we will set an exchange rate of
80 yen to a dollar instead of the
current 105 what will that do but
Japanese important will go to the Fed pa
TN get $1 bring American goods into
China India Japan and we don't have a we
have a for manufacturing base so it will
take a lot of dollar depreciation big
dollar depreciation to correct the trade
deficit and we can do it ourselves we
can set it to 80 yen to a dollar 70 yen
to a dollar whatever it takes to bring
America's export prices down so that our
imports our exports go up sharply what
our impulse won't fall so other
governments should not have much
objection which if at all to this system
and in any case they are doing it they
are setting the exchange rates
themselves we can set exchange rates at
least for our exporters or foreign
import so this is the system of dual
exchange rates which will not raise
import prices but effectively cut export
prices to other countries and then they
will buy more goods they will even buy
cars from Ford yes the Ford car is bad
but if you cut the price by 50% they'll
bite
they'll buy Arcia TVs I know it goes off
in the middle of the show but who keeps
paying 50% less we'll buy it you know
there are two ways to two reasons why
Goods sell high quality and low price if
the price is low enough I mean we are
buying Kia Kia's and Hyundai's the
quality has improved definitely but
perception is they are poor quality but
we're buying them because prices are low
for those goods
so this system of dual exchange rates
should cut our trade deficit at least
into 1/2 the trade deficit is right now
around 700 billion dollars a year
suppose we cut it by 300 billion and
suppose well when we cut the trade
deficit by 300 million our output will
rise by that much amount because we will
have to build that much hair and suppose
it takes 100,000 dollars to create a
high paying job it doesn't take that
much suppose it takes all that amount
$100,000 to create a high-paying
manufacturing job you divide 300 billion
by 100,000 you get 3 million that raises
America's employment that creates new
high-paying jobs equal to 3 million
right away we solve all of our problems
Social Security is supposedly in trouble
right now because growth is low trade
deficit is so high growth has to be low
revenues are not being created when the
growth rate jumps and the growth rate
jumps Social Security problem disappears
our budget deficit problem is solved
this is the key the straight deficit
problem is the key to our
salvation right now so what greenspan's
fraud has been has meant for America is
unethical economic policy in the 50s and
the 60s economic policy was ethical why
the poor paid very low taxes the
corporation's paid high taxes instead
the minimum wage was very high $8.00 in
terms of today's purchasing power versus
$5 today so we had a highly ethical
economic policy and the results were a
very very efficient economy not an
efficient stock market not a stock
market bubble but a fast rising living
standard a sharply rising living
standard for the vast majority of
Americans that that's what we had during
the 1950s in the 60s why because we had
ethical economic policy economic policy
has become unethical since 1980 and weak
you cannot expect efficient results from
unethical policies so we've had stock
market bubbles and then crashes huge
rise in poverty bankruptcies rising to
records two billion dollars of subsidy
from the rest of the world every day
every day that's that's what we need so
the entire world's economy is in a mess
so that's why I say let's try to go back
to those ethical policies and then we
will be able to solve all our economic
problems thank you very much
[Applause]
now if you have any questions then I
would request you to go to the mic to
ask a question there so everybody can
hear and then I will answer instead of
saying that Greenspan is unethical maybe
he does not know the economics and he
looks at the circumstances and changes
that's a very good point does Greenspan
change his theories when circumstances
change well as I said earlier during the
late 70s he opposed an income tax cut
from Carter because he said it would be
inflationary when Reagan was elected he
said let's cut the income tax to fight
inflation there is no change in
circumstances but there is a change in
the government so it's it's not the
circumstance that's moving him it's his
own self-interest my name is Ravi barker
and please explain me how can you use a
dual exchange rate when Chinese currency
is not open convertible okay the
question is how we can act unilaterally
to have a dual exchange rate system when
the Chinese currency is not convertible
we don't need that the importers in
China will would not need to go to their
central bank and buy dollars with their
Wang they can come directly to the Fed
pay six one to the Fed get one dollar
then that kind of incentive is available
why would they go to the Chinese
government to get dollars for the wrong
because there they have to pay eight
point two eight one if the system is if
we set up a system we say well we fixed
our exchange rate with respect to the
Vaughn 6 1 to $1 and that applies to all
foreign importers or American exporters
from America so the Chinese importers or
US exporters would not have to go to the
Chinese central bank to convert their
currencies into dollar you can come
directly to the Fed so the China that
doesn't have to do anything in this this
is the hover we can do it act on our own
because as I said exchange rates are
mutually set its exchange rate between
dollar between the dollar in the wall
not just the one itself so if so we can
unilaterally set it just the way China
is doing it and the Chinese importers
don't even have to go to their central
bank to get dollars my name is Wu
Pendred area and my question is if you
are talking about the economy the recent
problem the economy in USA is basically
what I feel greater goes to the
outsourcing and also the war in
Afghanistan and Iraq and if you tell
that all the blame should be put on
Greenspan I think that lot of things has
to do with some other outsource
protectors so I think if you can clarify
I would certainly appreciate okay
so the question is about the problems
caused by outsourcing and the war in
leicester basically near art oh and also
afghanistan first of all I have never
heard before that Wars hurt the American
economy look at First World War Second
World War the American economy comes up
shiny look at Vietnam War the Korean War
the economic American economy comes
shining this is the first time I'm
hearing that war is hurting our economy
worse
will hurt the American economy if they
are fought on the American soil yes the
civil war destroyed American economy but
other wars have helped the American
economy because it creates more
government spending government spending
creates more demand output has to rise
because of rising demand so I really
don't believe that the Iraq war is
hurting the American economy others
other Wars never did except for the
Civil War now the question of
outsourcing I think that problem could
be attributed to Greenspan himself
because he has not blamed he has not put
any blame on that outsourcing for
America's troubles but there is really
nothing we can do about outsourcing
other than except if we want to withdraw
from WTO that's the only way to take
care of outsourcing if we want to stay
within the free trade system within the
system of globalization we can't do
anything about outsourcing but as far as
the trade deficit is concerned we can do
something about it if we set up our
exchange rate it should be okay because
other countries are doing it to Japan
and China and Taiwan South Korea they're
all setting their exchange rates with
respect to the dollar so outsourcing may
be hurting the US economy most likely it
is or there's nothing we can do about it
and Greenspan himself has encouraged it
so but but the problem of trade deficit
is within our own hand and we can do
something about it
dr. Barker a great Heffron within depos
magazine and I have two questions you
sort of hitting that one one is are you
advocating that other nations who have
terrible trade deficits set up a dual
exchange policy because it sounds like
it could work and two how do you protect
against fraud in this particular
situation because it's obviously you're
getting special privileges from the Fed
would that be a problem
well other countries don't have to do
anything in the matter of the dual
exchange standard if it is set up by it
it has to be set up by the US government
especially the Fed and as I said say we
set an exchange rate of 80 yen to one
dollar
that's the Fed policy the importer in
Japan would not then go to his central
bank he would come to the Fed and say
here take my 80 yen give me a dollar
they are charging a hundred and five yen
why would he go to that and so that's
unilateral action we can take ourselves
and it should not really offend the
Government of Japan because the Japanese
goods all have the same prices as before
so other countries should not get in
what will not get involved and if they
do get involved too bad because they are
the ones who are setting who are
creating the problem to begin with and I
want the possibility of fraud we only
care to answer that question the Fed
simply has to police it better and it
will it will apply only to exporters of
American American goods or importers of
American goods it will not apply to any
other transaction for all other
transaction international transactions
they will use the free market foreign
exchange value of the dollar
my name is Naveen doshi I don't know
maybe I'm confused
but I have a problem if if I buy a
dollar with 80 yen would might the
product that I have imported from Japan
wouldn't that become cheaper and I could
possibly re-export
the this you are not importing product
from Japan the Japanese guys importing
for product from the US it will not
apply to America's imports for all other
transactions
except for the for American exports the
free market well free value of the
dollar will apply it will apply only to
American exports or foreign imports I
see so in others there would be a
restriction that only american-made
product has to be exported right for
that price
that's why not a wonders that's why the
dual exchange exercising no no but let's
say I got a camera from Japan being a
small so there is not that much of a
Freight problem and now the same camera
has become 20% cheaper to send it back
to Japanese camera a camera is not
cheaper the American camera is cheaper
to the Japanese so American codec can
export cameras there you know the
American goods are cheaper to the
Japanese cheaper to the Chinese
what other prices are more or less
unchanged that's the that's what this
dual exchange rate system my name is
Joseph to Bo I'm an SIU grad too by the
way but I'm here an answer here's the
two questions for you
we're at the Supreme Court the u.s.
United States now we think that the
entire Federal Reserve System is a fraud
we think that mr. Greenspan is but a a
pimp if you will in the international
waters the Ninth Circuit ruled that the
Federal Reserve is a private
organization part of the BIS Bank of
International Settlements
which has been adjudicated to be private
so on June 5 33 House Joint Resolution
it was passed that assigned all the
assets of America to the Federal Reserve
and a B is why is that not in the
military coup d'etat this is a loaded
question and
it is true that the unlimited power that
the federalism has in money creation
creates problems for the American worker
in the sense that whenever wages fall
behind productivity so demand falls
behind supply the Fed can simply lower
interest rates keya create more debt and
set and keep a balance in the economy if
if the Fed did not have the power the
power to create money at any time if
they did not have this unlimited power
say say money supply was backed by some
kind of some amount of gold you know you
did not have the power of creating money
to the unlimited to the infinite amount
that you want then Greenspan would not
be able or the Fed would not be able to
create a balance in the economy so the
imbalance would arise imbalance would be
created by wages falling behind
productivity and then they would have to
do something serious they would have to
introduce reforms that will allow people
to claim higher wages with rising
productivity to that extent I feel that
the unlimited power that the Fed has to
create money without any backing of gold
is harming the the people the public
general public but other things about
the Federal Reserve System itself is a
fraud I really don't want to get into
that I think that it affects this
country though all due respect this the
second question I have for you which
ties in the Constitution has five words
regulate the value thereof the founding
fathers are most sensitive they had a
importance about funny money none
substantive back money the Federal
Reserve field money is not backed by
anything okay you start back by anything
okay be printed at will
okay what's to the the inflation that we
have
devaluation purchasing powers in the
toilet okay why is that constitutionally
wrong well notice creating power
problems I mean it created the stock
market bubble then to fix the problems
of the stock market crash he printed a
lot of money and that has created a
housing bubble now which could also
burst sometime this decade it is
creating those problems but but I think
without the Federal Reserve we would
lose a stabilizing influence that that
could be needed during an emergency so I
won't what to get get rid of Federal
Reserve I would what to have I wanted to
I would like it to be run by somebody
Attica somebody with a degree from the
Department of spirituality and religion
from LMU mr. Batra I wonder if you could
speak to the popularity of a valent
Greenspan and how he has survived all
these years he seems to have an image of
this grandfatherly almost doctor or
priest that is blessing the basic
economic policies of the country and
that kind of curries favor for him in
the popular imagination could you
comment well that certainly used to be
his image I don't know if that image
still persists not sure when the
democrats of harry mr. reid the other
day called him a political hack there
are many others who are criticizing him
now I have received many emails from the
readers of this book congratulating me
for finally standing up to st. Alan
Greenspan exposing him exposing the
Emperor and so on but you're right and
there was a time when his popularity was
uncontested
he was revered as the maestro the best
economist ever he had more better
reputation than Nobel Prize winners
combined and so on
and and how how was he able to do that
without a PhD in economics is not ever
writing a scholarly article and so on
well he was and is a social charmer
great Boozer you might say and he
invited politicians to his parties
agreed to babysit for them I mean I'm
just kidding but well something like
that and and then he would talk about
both sides of the issue
he knows the Democrats don't like some
some policies the Republicans also
dislike other policies he would advocate
one policy once that has been adopted he
would come back he would talk about the
other side so people would think well
he's on he's a reasonable moderate man
he's not an extremist he was forced to
become an extremist after Bush's
election because their politics became
very extreme and then now that he know
it needs only George Bush can extend his
tenure at the Fed so he has had to
support his extremist policies and
that's why the Democrats finally find
out that he's not a moderate after all
he's for himself but for a long time he
was able to fool the public simply by
arguing on both sides of an issue as a
simple example he intervened in the
markets at least four times if I if I if
I recall properly there was a Mexican
crisis in nineteen ninety-four Asian
crisis in 1997 Russian debt default in
1998 and then at the same time this
long-term capital management crisis each
time he intervened in the market
and within months after after the
intervention he would say we love I love
free markets free markets are great but
he is just intervened so people think
well this is a free market man and he
had to intervene during the emergency
but emergencies were being created
because of his own policies so that's
why he was able to stay above politics
for a long time because the politics
itself was not so extreme but now
there's great polarization in the
country and he has had to support Bush's
policies and now that I'm image is going
because he want to he's reversed to
ensure that the number 1 is reappointed
so he offers supports those extremist
policies and now he's being exposed if
there are no more questions then can you
call it a day or something thank you for
being with us thanks a lot
[Applause]
ravi batra is a professor of economics
at Southern Methodist University in
Dallas greenspan's fraud how to decades
of his policies have undermined the
global economy is published by Palgrave
Macmillan
visit Palgrave